one more note on the tops friendly
market it's the only full-service
grocery store in this part of buffalo
almost everyone in the neighborhood was
a customer and that's also why so many
see this not only as an attack on a
store or a random group of shoppers on a
saturday but on an entire community of
black americans
we turned down laurel street heading
away from the tops friendly market and
almost immediately we see her my
mother's been here for 64 years 64 years
64 years retired nurse der hilda brown
outside the bright yellow home she grew
up in close enough to the scene to have
heard the shots
for something like this to happen
to be targeted to be targeted it's hard
it's heartbreaking just about everyone
around here knows one of the victims she
says or feels grateful that they weren't
one of them
my sister was enough and a friend
that lives down the street they were on
their way and then they decided not to
go
at 2 30. where are you emotionally with
all this are you angry are you sad are
you scared i'm sad you can't get angry
because
racism has always been around
i remember when we grew up i don't
remember seeing this much anger in
people
and such a level of disrespect
it's just it's just not it's not right
and it's heartbreaking
it really is
across the street we spot a young family
one-year-old cameron in his father's
arms and his mother kajane who grew up
here too and remembers going to tops for
greens before sunday dinner i was just
in shock honestly because of the
shooting she says she's angry and hurt
but also scared in a way she never has
been before
i went to alta earlier i was surrounded
by white people and i was honestly i
felt a little afraid i felt
like anything could happen and i was
afraid just getting makeup
fear is also on the mind of abdul mata
ali who flagged us down to say he's been
haunted by video of the shooting
i had to literally sit down because i
almost passed out what will propel a
person
to act in a census violent like that and
on top of that in the video it showed
that
he
encountered a caucasian man
and he apologized to him and he didn't
shoot him it was gwendolyn taylor who
sent him the clip and told us this is
her first time out of the house and
seeing it you attack a store where
everybody got those people in the store
that was victimized it was all of us
have you heard from other people who
feel like you do who feel absolutely my
family members was calling me like don't
go outside we met them along with their
granddaughter sabrina both say they're
afraid for the future i'm very fearful
very fearful especially for us as
african-americans
you know what i mean we can't change the
color of our skin people talk about
progress people talk about change no
there's not been if anything i think
it's been growing behind closed doors
bigger than ever we still live in an
unjust and racist society we still do
but back outside the tops market we met
pastor tim newkirk whose sister and
niece survived the shooting as employees
inside the store
and who had a message that surprised us
if you could say something to the gunman
what would it be we're praying for you
and we're asking god to forgive you and
forgive all of your sins
and despite the tragedy we should point
out that the pastor also told us that
the people in this community they remain
strong they remain united and they want
to reject everything that this shooter
tried to do and they're going to rebuild
they're going to reopen this store and
they're going to make the community safe
once again and gail nate vlad as i send
it back to you also point out that
the pastor's sister and niece are doing
okay he told us they're in a quiet place
having a respite from all of this back
to you guys
all right tony thank you so much i i was
struck by what mr ali said in tony's
piece that it's haunting i still can't
imagine how this young man at 18 had so
much hate and it's not just against
blacks you know the jewish community is
under tax lgbtq is under attack asian
americans are in this attack racism is
no longer on the fringes racism is
mainstream and that is very very very
scary to me this company i mean this
country excuse me this country is under
attack five mass shootings yeah since
friday yeah i mean gun violence is
as american as apple pie the sports we
watch and the hot dogs we eat at those
games yeah we have to admit that we have
to come to that real estate where is
safe can't go to a grocery store to pick
up some strawberries can't go to a
concert can't go to a movie can't go to
school can't go to a place of work no
synagogue a church i heard somebody in
buffalo you're right nate i heard
someone in buffalo say this is a story
that you see in other cities not nars
but now ours is it is like a a russian
roulette no matter where you are
nothing's still safe to me
very very scary and i think people are
tired of saying let's be strong tired of
being strong yeah